in the last video we took the Maclaurin
expansion of e to the X and we saw that
it looked like it was some type of a
combination of the polynomial
approximations of cosine of X and of
sine of X but it's not quite because
there were a couple of negatives in
there if we were to really add these two
together that we did not have when we
took the representation of e to X of e
to the X but to reconcile these I'll do
a little bit of a I don't know if you
can even call it a trick let's see if if
we take this polynomial expansion of e
to the X this approximation what happens
and if we say if we say e to the X is
equal to this especially as this becomes
an infinite number of terms then it
becomes less of an approximation and
more of an equality what happens if I
take e to the i-x and before that might
have been kind of a weird thing to do we
write it down e to the i-x because
before it's like how do you define e to
the I that's a very bizarre thing to do
to take something to the X I power how
do you even comprehend some type of a
function like that but now that we can
have a polynomial expansion of e to the
X we can maybe make some sense of it
because we could take I to different
amounts to different powers and we know
what that gives you know I squared is
negative 1 I to the third is negative I
so on and so forth so what happens if we
take e to the i-x so once again it's
just like taking the X up here and
replacing it with an IX so everywhere we
see the X and it's polynomial
approximation we would write an IX
so let's do that so e to the IX should
be approximately equal to and we'll
become more and more equal and this is
more to give you an intuition I'm not
doing a rigorous proof here but it's
still profound not to oversell it but I
don't think I can oversell
what is about to be discovered or seen
in this video it would be equal to 1
plus instead of an X will have an IX
plus I X plus so what's IX squared so
it's going to be so let me write this
down what is I x squared over 2
factorial
well I squared is going to be negative 1
then you can have x squared over two
factorial so it's going to be minus x
squared over two factorial I think you
might see where this is going to go and
then what is IX remember everywhere we
saw an X we're going to place it with an
IX so what is IX to the third power
actually let me write this out let me
not let me not skip some steps over here
so this is going to be I x squared over
2 factorial actually let me I want to do
it just the way so plus plus I x squared
over 2 factorial plus I X to the third
over 3 factorial plus I X to the fourth
over 4 factorial and we can keep going
plus I X to the fifth over 5 factorial
and we could just keep going so on and
so forth but let's evaluate these I X is
raised to these different power so this
will be equal to one plus I X I x
squared that's the same thing as I
squared times x squared I squared is
negative one so this is negative x
squared over two factorial and then this
is going to be the same thing as I to
the third times X to the third I to the
third is the same thing as I squared
times I so it's going to be negative I
so this is going to be minus I times X
to the third over 3 factorial and then
so then plus then plus you're going to
have what's I to the fourth power so
that's I to this I squared squared so
that's negative 1 squared that's just
going to be one so I to the fourth is 1
and then you have X to the fourth so
plus X to the fourth over 4 factorial
and then you're going to have plus we
ought to only write the plus it I to the
fifth so I to the fifth is going to be 1
times I so it's going to be I times X to
the fifth over 5 factorial so plus I
times X to the fifth or
or five factorial and I think you might
see a pattern here coefficient is one
then I then negative one then negative I
then one then I then negative 1x the
sixth over 6 factorial over six
factorial and then negative I and then
negative I X to the seventh over 7
factorial so we have some terms some of
them have some of them are imaginary
they have an eye there might be x I some
of them are real
why don't we separate them out why don't
we separate them out so once again e to
the i-x is going to be equal to this
thing especially as we add an infinite
number of terms well let's separate out
the real and the non real terms all
right or the real and the imaginary
terms I should say so this is real this
is real this is real and this right over
here is real and I obviously we could
keep going on with that so the real
terms here are 1 minus x squared over 2
factorial plus X to the 4th over 4
factorial and you might be getting
excited now minus X to the sixth over 6
factorial and that's all I've done here
but they would keep going so plus so on
and so forth so that's all of the real
terms and what are the imaginary terms
here and let me just I'll just factor
out the eye over here actually let me
just factor out so it's going to be plus
plus I times well this is IX so this
will be X and then the next so that's an
imaginary term this is an imaginary term
we're factoring out the eye so minus X
to the third over 3 factorial over 3
factorial then the next imagine terms
right over there we factor out the I
plus X to the fifth over 5 factorial and
then the next imaginary term is right
there we factored out the I so it's
minus X to the seventh over 7 factorial
and then we obviously would keep going
so plus minus keep going so on and so
forth preferably to infinity so that we
get as good of approximation as possible
so we have a situation where
e to the i-x is equal to is equal to all
of this business here but you probably
remember from the last few videos the
real part this was the polynomial this
was the Maclaurin this was a mole or an
approximation of cosine of X around zero
or I should say the Taylor approximation
around zero or we could also call it the
Maclaurin approximation so this and this
are the same thing so this is cosine of
X especially when you add an infinite
number of terms cosine of X this over
here is sine of X the exact same thing
so it looks like we're able to reconcile
how you can add up cosine of X and sine
of X to get something that's like e to
the X this right here is sine of X and
so if we take it for granted I'm not
rigorously proving it to you that if you
were taking an infinite number of terms
here that this will essentially become
cosine of X and if you took an infinite
number of terms here this will become
sine of X it leads to a fascinating
fascinating formula we could say that e
to the i-x e to the i-x is the same
thing as cosine of X is cosine of X and
you should be getting goose pimples
right around now is equal to cosine of X
plus I times sine of X and this is
Euler's formula I always pronounce I'm
right over here and this right here is
Euler's or Euler's formula and if that
by itself isn't exciting and crazy
enough for you because it really should
be because we've already done some
pretty cool things we're involving E
which we get from from continuous
compounding interest we have cosine and
sine of X which are ratios of right
triangles it comes out of the unit
circle and somehow we've thrown in the
square root of negative 1 there seems to
be this cool relationship here but it
becomes extra cool and we're going to
assume we're operating in radians here's
if we take if we assume Oilers formula
what happens when X is equal to PI just
to throw in another wacky number in
there the ratio between the
circumference of the diameter of a
circle what happens when we throw in PI
we get E
to the I pi e to the I PI is equal to
cosine of pi cosine of pi is what cosine
of pi is cosine of pi pi is halfway
around the unit circle so cosine of PI
is negative 1 and then sine of pi is 0
so this term goes away so if you
evaluated at PI you get something
amazing this is called Euler's identity
Euler's identity I always have trouble
pronouncing Euler Euler's identity which
we could write like this or we could add
1 to both sides and we could write it
like this and I'll write it in different
colors for emphasis e to the I times pi
plus 1 plus 1 is equal to I'll do that
in a neutral color is equal to I'm just
adding 1 to both sides of this thing
right over here is equal to 0 and this
this is thought-provoking I mean here we
have just so you see I mean this tells
you that there's some connectedness to
the universe that we don't fully
understand or at least I don't fully
understand I is defined you know by
engineers for simplicity so that they
can find the roots of all sorts of
polynomials as as as you could say the
square root of negative 1 the square
root of negative 1 pi is the ratio
between the circumference of a circle
and its diameter once again another
interesting number but it seems like it
come from a different place as I ecomes
from a bunch of different places e you
can either think of it it comes out of
continuous compounding interest super
valuable for finance it also comes from
the notion that the derivative of e to
the X is also e to the X so another
fascinating number but once again
seemingly unrelated to how we came up
with I and seemingly unrelated to how we
came up with PI and then of course you
have some of the most profound basic
numbers right over here you have 1 1 I
don't have to explain why one is a cool
number and I shouldn't have to explain
why 0 is a cool number and so this right
here connects all
of these all of these fundamental
numbers in some mystical way that shows
that there's some connectedness to the
universe so frankly frankly if if this
does not blow your mind you really you
have no emotion